I think I'm gonna take that first bite
just naked oh my gosh
[Applause]
[Music]
there are great burgers everywhere in
NYC but only a few special ones deserve
the title classic today I'm on a mission
to track down two of New York City's
best and most iconic burgers that have
stood the test of time one from an
old-school tavern and the other from a
storied Steakhouse and I'm linking up
with my friend an OG New Yorker Adam
Richman to show me what these legendary
burgers are all about Adam bro come on
dude
last time we linked up we explored the
idea of the baller for all the burgers
yes got any idea what we're gonna do
today
I'm a classic man mm-hmm
now I'm a new New Yorker uh-huh you're
no genie New Yorker oil to the soil yeah
what makes an iconic New York burger to
me I think the place plays a major role
like the place has to have history I
think generally in New York the classic
burgers are the ones that are like the
least adorned but like have really good
ingredients right now we're in the Upper
East Side direct and then we're gonna go
to your burrow Brooklyn a burger can put
a borrow on the map a restaurant can put
a neighborhood you know and give it kind
of cultural significance or culinary
significance whereas otherwise people
wouldn't go I'm pretty excited are you
pretty excited man well let's crush
these two New York legends I'm ready
let's do it the J and the G stand for
Jack and George my husband and his
partner and they opened melons in 1972
when they first took this space there
was a watercolor of a melon behind the
bar and then people just started
bringing in pictures drawings a lot of
people that come here say they feel like
they're coming home I think it's because
of us it's an iconic New York landmark
if you come to New York you go to JG
melons it's about relating to people
I've been coming here since I guess 79
and I met my husband in 84 and we used
to date in here
Margy used to wait on us I'm Bobby and
what I do that's the OL finesse question
I've been here too I tell girls over 30
years was actually over 40 I feel like
the key for
missions I thought your Valachi yeah you
know I've had customers come up and then
say yeah how do I get a back up there I
don't know that you really want one
because these were customers that have
passed away the first one started with
the win over Table one Steve's table I
get attached to my customers I really
feel like we talked about Steve I mean I
think you're gonna have me here for a
long time I'm having issues I don't know
if I'm able to like be mellifluous or
funny I just so want to bite it I think
I'm kind of worthless I apologize to
everyone who first we feast I know I was
hired to be sound by the machine but all
I want to do is kind of steal from my
buddy Eric beanie I just kind of want to
[ __ ] this with my face we're walking
into JG melon we're in the Upper East
Side just looks like an average Irish
bar but it's burger Mecca
everything is beautiful mahogany
old-world green gingham tablecloth
watermelons everywhere everywhere red
ceiling classic bar that has every
whiskey you could imagine and then boom
this thing arrives in front of your face
what are you feeling right now man cuz
like for me I'm not I'm holy I've only
been in New York for three years but I
haven't giddy like a child or it is
nostalgia like I do remember like I had
a hook up here and I had a break up down
at that into the bar real talk
this is very comforting to me because
this was the burger I had before I had a
career in food before you go to the
kitchen this is this is mandatory yeah
that's dope where it's timeless it's
like it's like biggie
it's like Air Force Ones it said it was
awesome thirty years ago and still hot
as [ __ ] today we put on me for sure the
first two and that's about it
pickles for sure 100% all the time I
love that they do the cottage fries I'm
still hot it's nice guys it's like
ruffles on steroids yeah word that's
very good explanation I think I'm gonna
take that first bite just naked oh I
just want to eat my feelings like a
Cathy cartoon oh my gosh it's amazing it
tastes like a steak in a bun and every
time I come here I'm amazed because I
see one tiny griddle they're doing so
many burgers I think he's like 600
burgers a day it blows my mind that they
could keep the thing hot enough to get a
sear this well it's incredible this is
damn near perfect this is like a ninety
nine point technique I mean that's the
thing right it's like it's not a cheese
that's obscure you can't name it
I started jam made out of something
that's not commonly made into a jam and
I think that's the thing and I'm never
the dude who's like I don't want to add
ketchup and stuff I'm a condom at home
but like this one really as one of those
things that like the cheese and the
juiciness of the meat almost make its
own condiment it's delicate it's a
delicate patty even though it's thick
it's almost like you're chewing through
like a beef croissants it's like layers
it falls down like that like it crumbles
in your mouth I'm a big fan of Picasso
and I know he said younger artists we're
trying to do crazy [ __ ] and he did and
he said you know you have to learn color
theory composition brushstrokes before
you can start deviating from it and I
feel this is the form upon which the new
burger place is free-style
we just had the Platonic idea of a New
York City bar burger oh yeah now we're
off to your burrow BK all day we're
gonna get a burger in the most classic
Steakhouse in all of New York
just do it I'm super excited finishing
this first though yeah let's get it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right then this is an honor because
I respect you and I've got eat with you
in New York but never in Brooklyn and
neither one of us has had the burger
before I've never had the burger I've
come here so many times they're known
for dry-aged porterhouse and a dry-aged
it was you can smell - the moment you
walk in the first thing that hits your
nose dude it's always been shared the
filet yeah a piece of the porterhouse
then run it into vitamins which they
didn't top we can't taste the burger
without having the first taste this dry
aged steak this beautiful piece of meat
I don't even think you need a knife for
that's ridiculous
sear is great it's seasoned perfectly
and it's melting in my mouth and it
maintains its crunch through the bite no
matter how juicy it gets Peter Luger was
founded as Cora Lugar's cafe and
billiards in 1887 the last 69 years it's
been in my family's business our
hamburger is really an exercise in
simplicity that ain't broke don't fix it
this staff who've made their careers
with us they really form the fabric of
the restaurant their people have been
with us for upwards of three decades for
decades
my name is Catalina Breton and I've been
working for a bit I loved it for four
years now and I'm having a little fun
it is an institution and I'm very proud
boys like a family we feel like you know
just a second family my name is Carl
Taylor I'm here for 35 years yeah it is
a family that's why everybody's here for
for many many years
oh yeah people proposed all the time
here you know the tutoring in the cake
tip balance within the state and other
stuff you know that happens all the time
here
it's the purists dream talk about me
cheese bun Peter Luger is a lunch only
burger dude
[Music]
seated fun try aged beef blend American
cheese whole section of onion I love it
it's like a primal burger this makes me
want to go on like a Viking raid with
like a [ __ ] mace in my ham you know
when we were walking in they had those
boilers they didn't have a griddle they
cook these burgers on the same broiler
like that as they cook their say same
the same way and like you get that
almost like chip sear on the steak you
get the same thing in the burger and
it's just it's lights out I just I'm
really I'm not manufacturing because I
look you and I [ __ ] the cameras I'm
looking you man-to-man and that's a
friend yeah I'll tell you you don't talk
I am blown away so I have to do the
traditional move you know throw on the
bib and just and just go to sleep [ __ ]
but what I took away from the day what
I've learned about our iconic New York
burger journey is that in New York it's
all about the beach it's all about the
thick patty the steak flavors the steak
vibe like your blend yeah your blood
that's someone it's not just chuck a
burger with pedigree bro yeah cuz like
you oh my boys a burger knows like thick
patties are for [ __ ] I'm about it
I'm honored to represent the classics of
my city amazing to you and thank you for
taking me on this journey oh thanks for
coming with me of course y'all don't get
it twisted I'm still eating after they
wrap but that [ __ ]
[Music]
you
[Music]
what's up burger fam it's Alvin kai-lan
from the burger show
thank you for your continual support
make sure you hit that like button smash
that subscribe button
turn on your notifications if not for me
for the burgers
please and thank you